a prodisantis pack has released an ad
which ran for the first time on Fox News
yesterday directly attacking Donald
Trump the the ad itself is pretty lame
from a factual standpoint what's
important about this is the fact that
the attacks themselves are a major part
of what's going on right now the uglier
the primary
the worse it is for republicans and for
whoever is the eventual nominee the type
of Republican party that exists today is
a resentful grudge-holding Republican
party with a particularly uninformed
electorate who often only cares about
one candidate and so what we've seen is
that the more divisive the primary it
can lead to these irreparable fractures
and factions within the Republican Party
supporters of different candidates who
become disillusioned disillusioned when
their candidate loses and they may not
even end up voting in the general
election